nicolas sarkozy sur les terres de
françois bayrou officiellement pour
inaugurer une usine
officieusement pour vanter les bienfaits
du dialogue entre adversaires politiques
c'est une nouvelle preuve du
réchauffement des relations entre les
deux hommes qui se sont déjà vus deux
fois ces dernières semaines
pour autant le président du modem assure
garder son indépendance et ses
convictions
caroline l'inter guillaume barbier
la poignée de main est franche et
surtout elle a lieu en public permis les
entretiens en catimini de ces dernières
semaines deux au total à l'elysée depuis
la fin avril
françois bayrou est ce que on peut
clairement dire aujourd'hui que vous
êtes en plein réchauffement politique
avec nicolas sarkozy dont le
réchauffement politique c'est votre
fantasme
ce qui
ce qui a été dit
que j'approuve
c'est qu'il est des circonstances dans
la vie d'un pays
bien qu'étant en désaccord et même en
opposition on a le devoir sur les grands
sujets de réfléchir si on peut ensemble
et de travailler si on peut ensemble et
ensemble ils ont inauguré aujourd'hui l'
usine de moteurs d'hélicoptères
turbomeca à bordes dans la
circonscription béarnaise du président
du modem le ton chaleureux n'est pas
encore au rendez vous mais cette visite
présidentielle a permis à nicolas
sarkozy de rappeler que l'union fait la
force
pour nos compatriotes qui souffrent tant
de la crise c'est plutôt rassurant de
voir des gens différents capables de
s'additionner
c'est ça la notion qu'on a donné pas moi
plus que vous vous moi douce ici on a
donné le visage d'une france qu'on
aimerait voir plus souvent
une france rassemblée pour préparer
l'avenir
nicolas sarkozy semble vouloir continuer
aujourd'hui sa stratégie d'apaisement
les cherche à l'équation qui pourrait
rassembler les contraire affirment
certains de ses proches
une équation à plusieurs inconnues en
vue de 2012